- DA STRUGGLE IN THE HOUSE.
USING WORDS AND RHYMES
TO GET THROUGH HARD TIMES.
YEAH. COME ON.
[hip hop music]
♪ I CAME FROM THE STREETS
WITH NOTHING IN MY POCKETS ♪
♪ NO FOOD, NO BOOKS,
NO POWER IN THE SOCKETS ♪
♪ EACH BATTLE I FIGHT,
A ROLE MODEL AND A TEACHER ♪
♪ HIP HOP, MY CHURCH,
EVERY RAPPER A PREACHER ♪
- ♪ I PREACH FROM MY ASS,
MY FARTS IS MY SERMONS ♪
♪ THE CHURCH IS YOUR MOUTH
WHERE I SHOOT MY HOLY SPERM IN ♪
♪ YOU CAN TAKE YOUR ROLE MODELS,
ROLL 'EM ON MY MEAT ♪
♪ BITCHES ALWAYS ON THE MENU
WHEN I GO OUT TO EAT ♪
♪ ♪
- ♪ BUT EVERYWHERE WE GO ♪
♪ WE DON'T FORGET
THE STRUGGLES, SON ♪
♪ BLACK WOMAN,
TWO JOBS, TWO KIDS ♪
♪ TOO TIRED TO JUGGLE 'EM ♪
- ♪ JUGGLE 'EM, JUGGLE 'EM,
JIGGITY, JIGGITY JUGGLE 'EM ♪
♪ YUM, YUM, YUMMY ♪
♪ TITTY TITTIES
IN MY TUMMY, YUM ♪
♪ ♪
♪ TITTIES IN MY MOUTH,
I GOT TITTIES IN MY MOUTH ♪
♪ I GOT TIG OL' BITTIES FROM
A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT CITIES ♪
♪ I GOT-- ♪
[soul music]